oh I'm from the East Coast so I've heard  of them but I've never I've never had  one  who put this together  I got clam juice and tomato juice and  Maggie and yeah was someone like drunk  and they were just like yeah this sounds  like a good drink trip to Epcot like  going around the world but in one drink  yeah it smells like a spicy bloody man  it smells like a really drunk person's  vomit  cheers - Cheers in this runoffs ugly  saturday this is refreshing and Wow  well that's great I kind of like the  chiller version of a Bloody Mary it's  like what you would have when you don't  want to have like vodka if I have choice  between this and a Bloody Mary I'm  picking this it's like a little  carbonated but not like overly like I  hate this it feels like a perfect summer  drink something that you can have when  it's really really hot outside keep my  horses Shire sauce I'm mistake not at my  drink meanwhile I love it got this thank  you no more of this I feel so bad